c'est toujours pour les autres nous on
nous laisse dans notre coin ça rend fou
pourquoi on n'a pas le droit de partir
au ski exprimer son vécu pour mieux se
construire un objectif majeur du
dispositif raconte-moi ta vie créé par
le fond de dotation auteur solidaire
durant 20 heures d'ateliers c'est lycée
un des muraux était accompagné d'un
comédien dans l'écriture d'un récit sur
leur propre histoire une façon de gagner
en confiance pour ses élèves parfois
éloignés du monde culturel ils ont des
choses à dire parce que voilà on est
quand même dans des filières très
techniques ou
l'imaginaire n'a pas forcément beaucoup
sa place qui ont des histoires parfois
folles parfois dur parfois drôle j'écris
sur mon parcours au basket je fais du
basket ça on va parler et j'ai bien
appris je me suis amélioré j'amène
j'amélioré mon communication grâce à lui
des récits du quotidiens laissant
parfois place à l'imaginaire une bulle
de liberté dans le contexte formel du
lycée les thèmes d'écriture des
anecdotes de stage ou encore la passion
du sport moi je m'étais inspiré d'un
film qui est sur Netflix qui s'appelle
Athéna c'est un film qui résume trois
l'histoire de trois frères il y en a un
qui meurt après les autres ils vont se
venger il y a un frère qui veut l'appel
autre qui veut la haine et j'essaie de
le remixer après ma façon aussi
à 18h ma vie ils ont un vocabulaire qui
est le leur et qui peut être très
intéressant et qui justement peut peut
être une vraie langue et un vrai un vrai
endroit de création deux récits de cette
classe du lycée Jacques Vaucanson seront
envoyés à un comité de lecture courant
janvier ces textes là derrière sont
proposés un jury qu'il est sélectionne
l'un des deux et qui va proposer de d'en
faire une soit une chanson soit un
podcast soit une vidéo les élèves
pourront ensuite réaliser l'oeuvre avant
une présentation au public en juin
prochain trois établissements et 99
élèves de l'académie de Versailles
participent à cette première édition
francilienne